on the mound for the astros today's
left-hander from valdez 9-5 a 3.080 ra
in 18 starts 111 innings 91 hits 45
walks 103 strikeouts leap adding 221
against romberg
there's the breaking ball pulled
bregman backs up and gets the out and
here is ohtani now 43 home runs leads
major league baseball he's driven in 93.
3-2 fastball line to right and deep and
gone
like a bullet 44 in the blink of an eye
that's the first home run that valdez
has allowed to a left-handed batter
third home run for shohei ohtani as a
starting pitcher that baseball got out
quickly he went with a fastball and it
ran on the inner half ball got out
114.7 miles per hour exit velocity that
is an absolute
it out and by the way he's pitching
tonight just for fun
and now gosselin sends one into
shallow center field kyle tucker and
chaz mccormick converge chaz
will make the call on the catch for out
number two
as adele sends one pretty deep to right
field tucker all the way back near the
wall and puts it away joe adele gives it
a ride but he's out number three oh tony
on the mound to face a very good astros
team and you see the numbers
really good post all-star break as well
the era is under three and the whip is
close to one
altuve base it into right field sharply
hit past the diving jared walsh good at
bat by jose altube to start this one for
the astros he's running
breaking ball hit to right
and lagarus is there to make the catch
and altuve retreats
ground ball towards the hole past the
diving phil gosselin into left field
alex bregman a 10 game hitting streak
continues to hit well coming off the il
alvarez lifts it
legarra squares it up altuve tags and
bluffs
that one on the ground gosling to second
fletcher is there ohtani out of the
inning walsh is heated up eight game
hitting streak he's had hits in the 11
of his last 13 games
there it is and he was on it lifts it
right center and deep tucker back it is
gone
jared walsh his 26th framber valdez had
not allowed a home run to a left-handed
hitter until otani hit one out and walsh
follows here in the second three breaker
balls that were very hittable in that
sequence
for walsh against valdez he stayed back
gotta break the ball got a lot more of
the plate
all three pitches very hittable and
walsh made him pay for it 26 home run 81
rbi
for walsh
swing and a miss suzuki goes down on
strikes that's the first strikeout for
from
got him breaking ball away back-to-back
strikeouts for frommer after the solo
home run second time through now for the
astros altuve with one out
that hits the bag that's a fair ball
down the left field line altuve hustling
to second and he will get there ahead of
the throw by jack mayfield jose altuve
with a double down the left field line
two outs out two base still a second
that'll bring up alex bregman that ball
through the middle that'll get into
center field for a hit altuve comes
around third he's going to score the
astros have cut the lead in half it's
now a 2-1 game alex bregman the rbi
single big two-out knock by alex bregman
tight ball game with the runner at
second base that shift is on wide open
for him to be able to punch that ball
up the middle the other way and he does
exactly that the astros get their first
run on the board and now jordan alvarez
bats
that ball's hit well deep to right field
all the way back lagaris and he will
watch it bounce off the wall bregman
heading to third he's going to be waved
around yard on alvarez the rbi double
we're tied up
big swing from the big man astros
getting some mistakes up out of the zone
and making hotani pave
here's correa runner on second it's 2-2
that ball into right center field
that'll be down jordan will score easily
carlos correa gives the astros a 3-2
lead it's 3-2
on the rbi single by carlos correa
two out lightning by the astros so let's
see what kurt suzuki can do he has a
pair in scoring position swings at the
pitch and grounds it out of the reach of
altuve that's going to drive in one and
that's it
angels will have runners at the corners
but have quickly come back to tie this
game up at three and still no one out
fastball chopper over the middle correa
has to go to first
angels get the run
another guy's in scoring position too
it's 4-3 and
that's situational hitting runners stay
at second and third now with one out
jose altuve will bat he is two for two
tonight there's a ground ball base hit
in between third and short that'll score
one run mccormick being held up altuve
ties the game at four with his third hit
of the night two swinging it joe madden
had an extensive discussion with matt
wise the pitching coach and finally
decided to come out
tony will leave the game here in the
fourth inning then andrew wentz is the
new pitcher the astros stay with runners
on first and third now with two outs and
alex bregman who is two for two now to
be on the go line drive down the left
field line at the fair ball headed
towards the corner one run scores
alternate will score astros lead six to
four two rbi double by brady
greg he's feeling it bases loaded two
outs in kyle tucker
catcher's interference will score a run
tucker fouls that ball up it'll be ruled
catchers interference and the astros now
lead seven to four all right the tenth
batter now for the astros this inning is
oledmi's diaz
there's a line drive base hit into right
field alvarez will score correa will
score tucker to third astros lead at
nine to four on the two rbi single by
led miss diaz amber valdez remains and
he'll face joe adele
the top of the fifth inning
adele to left field that's deep
mccormick at the wall and it is off the
wall bounces off near the top and adele
racing for third and he's gonna get
there the ball kicks away hits the
umpire adele still on his feet and he'll
score
that's a great base running aggressive
base running
you can't wait for a coach to say go he
just read that off him the baseball
weighs far enough with his speed he's
going to go all the way around to score
so a triple and an error just like that
pick up a run here's alex bregman he had
hits in his first three at bats and
drove in a total of three runs tonight
that ball hit high in the air to left
field
playable for gosselin should be deep
enough to score altuve he'll tag and
cross the plate with ease
astros in double figures sacrifice fly
makes it a 10 to five game alex bregman
a season high four runs batted in
ryan stanek on to try and close out this
10-5 lead
stanek picks up a called third strike
got goslin looking on a 3-2 pitch that
was 98 for the strikeout
that ball rope but right at bregman nice
backhand play alex bregman bregman going
down to a knee to pick up that
backhanded line drive off the bat of joe
adele
called third strike ball game over
astros win it 10-5 tonight they are now
3-1 on this home stand for the time
being they lead both the a's and the
mariners by six games in the al west
you